[müzik]
Evet. ABS'nin gülleri, yavru kurtlarım,
pembe panterlerim benim. 9. sınıflar.
Aa, 9. sınıf ürünesi bu. Bunlar a yeni
MEB Maarif modeli gereğince Milli Eğitim
Bakanlığı 9. sınıf ve 10. sınıf
kitaplarını güncelledi. Geçen sene 9.
Onlar güncellendi. Ha içeride şöyle bir
şey yaptılar. üniteleri birleştirdiler.
Mesela tarihin ilk ünitesi tarih
bilimine girişti önceki yıllarda. Şimdi
geçmişin inşa sürecinde tarih oldu.
Sonra eski çağ medeniyetleri ve orta çağ
medeniyetleri diye üç ünitede bitirdi.
Ayrıca bir İslam öncesi Türk tarihi,
ayrıca bir İslam tarihi, ayrıca bir
Ortaşad Avrupa tarihi diye bir ünite
yok. Hepsini birinin içine
yerleştiriverdi. Ama burada şöyle bir
sıkıntı oldu. Ha güzellik de oldu. Niye?
Mesela önüte ayırmış. demiş ki, "Eski
çağda yönetenler, savaşanlar demiş.
Şunların hepsini tek tek anlatmış."
Tamam. Oradaki 10 tane, 11 tane
uygarlığı anlatmış. Ondan sonrasında
eski çağda hukuk demiş, bir daha
anlatmış. Eski çağda inanç, bilim, sanat
demiş, bir daha anlatmış. Böyle ben
mesela Çin deyip hepsini aynı anda
anlatacağım, geçeceğim. İşte Hint deyip
hepsini aynı anda anlatıp geçeceğim.
Mısır deyip anlatıp geçeceğim. Artık
bize bu tüme gelim, tümden gelim, tüme
varım yöntemler yeni marif modelinde
kullanılıyor. Kazanımlar aynı ama şurada
anlaması birazcık daha kolay oluyor.
Niye? Çünkü Çin'i anlatıyorsun. Çin'in
mesela 10 bilgi varsa üçünü burada ilk
ünitede veriyorsun. Üçüncüyü ikincisinde
veriyorsun. Diğer kalan dört bilgiyi de
öbür ünitede veriyorsun. Kopuk gibi
oluyor. Anlaştık. O yüzden ben gene
bildiğim usulde anlatıvereceğim sana ki
sonuçta bunun hepsini anlatacağım.
Kazanımlarını da vereceğim. Hadi
bismillahirrahmanirrahim.
Şimdi geldim neye? İlk çağ uygarlıkları
ve ilk çağdaki uygarlıklar MEB'in
kitabına göre de eski çağ medeniyetleri
olan başlığa arkana yaslan. Hadi
bismillahirrahmanirrahim. Toplamda 10
tane uygarlık var. Ben seni sevdiğim
için 11inciyi de ekleyi verdim. MEB
kitabında sadece ufak bir parantezin
içinde vermiş. Maya, Toltek, Astek,
Inka, bilmem ne diye ama anlatmamış. O
yüzden bunların da olduğunu bilin. O
dönemde burada tam 10 tane uygarlığım
var. Erdem zomzomla beni şokam araya.
Kim onlar? Taban uygarlık. Çin, Hint,
Mısır, Roma, Ege, İran, Helen, Doğu
Akdeniz, Mezopotamya ve Anadolu olmak
üzere genelde soru nereden geliyor?
Mesotamya Anadolu. Bu ikisi üzerinden
geliyor. Bak bir de Amerikalılar var
dedik. İlk çağda Amerika yok da Amerika
kıtasında yaşayanlar daha bulunmadı. İlk
çağda ne zaman? Orta Çağ'da bulundu
orası. Anlaştık. Hah. Şimdi burada bile
şey değil. Hatta yeni çağda bulundu.
Yani hani bilin bilinmiyor. Amerika'da
Maya, Toltek, Asteinka var da haberimiz
bile yok. Onlardan tamam. Buraya hepsini
yazdım fakat bir tanesini yazmadım. Kimi
yazmadım?
Buraya sığmayacak kadar büyük olan bir
uygarlığı yazmadım. Çünkü onu ayrıca
anlatacağım. Kimleri yazmadım? Türkleri
yazmadım.
Tamam. Niye? Çünkü abeciğim bizim
tarihimiz buraya sıkıştırılmayacak kadar
büyüktür. Bak tamamen objektif,
tarafsız, yansız böyle anlatacağım ben
sana. Şimdi arkana yaslan. Listen to
very carefully. Şu Amerika'daki Maya,
Toltek, Astek, Inka kulağında kalsın.
İlk çağda bunlar da varmış. Tamam.
Amerika'da varmış ama henüz daha
bulunmadılar, bilinmiyorlar. Anlaştık.
Bu kadar bitti burası. Hah, şimdi geldim
en başa. Topda 1 numara. Survivor adası
eleme listesi gibi değil mi? Topon
listesi gibi değil mi? İlk başta Çin
var. Niye? Niye? Niye en başa Çin'i
yazdım da? Niye Mezopotamya? Niye
Anadolu? Niye Gitleri şunları yazmadım
da niye Çin yazdım? Abim Çin hep
Çin'deydi ya. La onlar hep oradalardı.
Onlar medeniyetin beşiği. Hakikaten de
şimdi sevmem. Tamam şu boydalar çekik
gözlüler öldür öldür bitmiyorlar. Adamı
öldürüyorsun aynısı 3 gün sonra karşına
çıkıyor. Sürekli dejavu yaşıyorsun. Lan
ben seni öldürmedim mi deyip bir daha
öldürüyorum. Sinir bozular ama hep
oradalardı.
Hep oradalardı. Dünya şu an işte işte 6
milyar 8 milyar hesap edemiyor.
Matematik etmiyor ona. Tamam mı? Hani 8
milyar desen 2 milyarı nerede? E orada
kurban olduğumun dünya niye 2327 o yana
doğru yatık? E Çin kalabalık diye. Ben
bunu da böyle anlattım. Coğrafyacılar
ikna edemediler. İşte kalabalık olunca o
taraf dünya bu tarafa doğru yatmıştır
falan anlatım. Alakası bilem yok. Ama
tarih dersinin coğrafyayla, felsefeyle
değil mi? Ahlak bilgisiyle bunlarla işte
sosyolojiyle ilgili alakalı olduğunu
biliniz. Çin medeniyetin beşiği abi.
Medeniyetin beşiği. Onlar hep
oradalardı. O çekik gözler hep
oradalardı. Onlar felsefe onlar için
önemli. Felsefeye önem vermişler. Bak
eğer bir devlet düşünceye önem
veriyorsa, düşünürlerini destekliyorsa,
bilimi destekliyorsa o medeniyet ister
istemez gelişir. Anlaştık. Onlar
gelişmişler işte. Hatta bunların peşeyi
peygamberleri konfücü, konfutuzu
dediğiniz adam işte konfücü. Bu adamın
görüşleri, düşünceleri bizim Mevlana'ya
benziyor. Hani Mevlana da diyor ya, "Gel
ne olursan ol gene gel bin kere tövbe
etsen de gel" diye. Bunların adamı da
aynı böyle sözlerle güzel özlü sözlerle
şeyler yapmış. Açıp bakabilirsiniz,
izleyebilir, okuyabilirsiniz yani hani.
Ve bunların şimdi bak yönetim manasında
baktığınızda Çin imparatorlukla
yönetiliyor ve hanedanlar sürmüş uzun
süre. Ne onlar? Yao hanedanı, milk
hanedanı, çun hanedanı, çan hanedanı,
çunk hanedanı ve adam takır tak
yuvarlamış. Ne ses çıkarsa çung yang
tangk tung fungk demiş geçmiş. Bir sürü
ne var? Hanedan var. Yani neyle
yönetildiler? Monarşi ile yönetildiler.
Mono latince mono, di tri, tetra bildin
mi? Mono bir arşi. Fransızca yönetim
birleştir. Monarşi tek adam yönetimi
var. Onları da mesela dersin sonunda
anlatıvereceğim. Monarşi işte
beraberinde teokrasi, oligarşi,
örneklerini vereceğim. MEB kitabı
bunların hepsini dağıtmış. Ayrı ayrı
anlatıyor. Bilin. Beraberinde mesela
dini ayrı anlatıyor. Mesela bunlar
mesela manizm, Budizm dinlerine
inanmışlar ama Çinlerin inanmadığı dinde
yok. Onlar da bayağı kalabalıklar. Ama
şu manyizm Budizm dini aslında bak
Manizm Budizm dini aslında Hint
dinleridir. Ama Hindistan'dan çok nerede
yayılmış? Çin'de yayılmış. Niye? Çin'in
nüfus e kalabalık. Kurban oldum. Çin'in
nüfus kalabalık. Bilin beraberinde neyle
uğraştılar? İlk çağda herkes neyle
uğraşıyor? İlk çağda herkes tarımla
uğraşıyor. E tarımla uğraşılan yerde
sınıf ayrımı mutlaka olur mu? Olur.
Kölecilik her yerde var mı? Var.
Kölecilik bak bu gördüklerinizin
tamamında var. Birinde yok. Kimde yok?
Biz Türklerde köle muhabbeti hiçbir
zaman yok. Yok. Niye? Bir fıtratımıza
ters. Biz bağımsızlığımıza düşkünüz. Ya
bağımsız oluruz ya bağımsız ölürüz. İki,
biz göçebeyiz. Tarım yok bizde. Anladın
yani hani ezberleme. Neyi anla?
Mantığını anla. Bilin. Beraberinde sınıf
ayrımı var mı? Var. Belirgin mi?
Belirgin. O Çin dizlerini falan, Kore
dizlerini falan. Hepiniz izliyorsunuz.
Biliyorum ben güttüğüm koyunu. Oralardan
görürsünüz. Ve bunlar parayı işte
tarımdan kazanacak, hayvancıktan
kazanacak. Ama asıl para nerede? Asıl
para ticarette. Rızkın 109'u nerededir?
Ticarettedir. Hadisinden. Aha. Bunlar da
neyle uğraşıyor? Ticaretle uğraşıyorlar.
Ve o dönem önemli ticaret yolları var.
Bunların en önemlisi ise hangisi? İpek
yolu. Sick road. Bildin mi? Peki bu yola
neden ipek yolu denmiş? Burada her şey
gidiyor geliyor, satılıyor, alınıyor,
ediliyor, kılıyor. Niye ipek yolu? Çünkü
burada giden en pahalı, en şey malzeme
ipek. En kalitelisi o, en pahalısı o. O
yüzden ne deniliyor? İpek yolu
deniliyor. Anlaştık. Yattım aklınıza. Ve
bu ipek yolu Çin'den başlıyor. Tek
Avrupa'ya kadar gidiyor. O arada da
kıvrım bütüm, kıvrım büklüm, kıvrım
büklüm. Herkes bu ipek yoluna egemen
olmak ister mi? İster. Devletler o
yüzden birbirleriyle ittifak yapıyor,
düşman oluyor, savaşıyor. Sen alacaksın,
ben alacağım. Niye? Ne gelecek ticaret
hocam? Ne alaka? Ticaret ne? Ne varsa
gelecek lan? Hiç bilemedin. Oraya bir
tane sandalye koy. Gelenden geçenden
vergi al. Kurban olduğum ne dönüyor
işte? Para dönüyor işte. Anlaştık. Asıl
para burada mesela bu dönem Orta Asya'da
olan bir yol daha var. Kürk yolu var.
Mesela İpek Yolu doğu batı eksenlidir.
Çin'den başlayıp t kıvrım büklüm
Avrupa'ya kadar gider. Bir de Kürk yolu
var mesela. O da yukarıdan Sibirya'dan
aşağıya doğru geliyor. Niye Kürk yolu?
Oradan da Kürkler gelip gidiyor.
Anlaştık. Bir yol daha var. Hintlilerin
kullandığı baharat yolu var mesela.
Anladın? O baharat yolu da mesela
Hindistan'dan Mısır'a kadar geliyor.
Bunlar hep doğu batı etkileşimini de
arttırır mı? Kuzey güney etkileşimini de
arttırır mı? Ticaret kültürel bir
etkileşim yolu mudur? Yoludur. Para var,
huzur var, muhabbeti var. Anlaştık.
Genel yapılarını bilin. Önemli. Niye
baharat yolu denmiş ona da? Bak onu da
mesela bak şuraya yazalım. Al beni.
Zomzomla beni. Zomzomla. Şuraya da
yazalım. Baharat yolu diye.
Tamam. Buna niye baharat yolu deniyor
buna? Neden? Çünkü burada da her şey
geliyor gidiyor. Fakat en kıymetli
malzeme ne? Baharat. O dönem buzdolabı
yok. Ee eti pişirdin, nudlu pişirdin. E
bozulmasın. Nasıl yapacaksın?
Baharatlarla tütsüleyip öyle kurtullar
öyle yerlermiş. Anladın? O yüzden
pahalı. Al. Ticaret yollarından da
bahsettik. Şu an bir ünitenin kazanımı
bitti. Haberin olsun. Anlaştık. Buraya
ayrı bir ünite olarak işte ticaret
yolları. Eskişehlerinde ticaret yolları
demiş. İpek yolu, kürk yolu, baharat
yolu. Bunlardan bahsediyor. Kapiş. Sonra
bir de ne var? Kral yolu var. Mesela
Anadolu'daki bizim parayı bulan var yok
mu? Lidyalılar onlarınki. oraya geldiğim
zaman tekrarlayıveririm bilin. Ve
Çinliler özellikle gel beni zomz zomla
beni gel. Özellikle Çinlilerin Türklerle
mücadele etmesinin sebebi,
asıl sebep ekonomiktir. Tamam biz de
savaşçıyız. Yayılmak istiyoruz, almak
istiyoruz. Gökyüzünün olduğu her yer
bizimdir anlayışı var değil mi? Ve
Çinliler, "Eim biz de göçebeyiz. Bizde
tarım yok. Parayı hayvancılıktan ne
kadar kazanabileceksin? E para nerede?
Ticarette." değil mi? Türklerde mesela
ipek yoluna sürekli biz de salça
oluyoruz. Sürekli Türk İran mücadelesi
var. Soru Türk ve neyle alınan Türk Çin
mücadelesinin en önemli sebebi nedir?
İpek Yoluna hakimiyet mücadelesidir.
Tamam biz bunlara gıcık oluyoruz. Küçük
boylar, çekik gözler hepsi birbirine
benziyor falan ama asıl sebep totally
emotional. Biz Türkler nasıl diyor?
Tamamen duygusaldır ve herifler ne
ettilerse o dönem abim onlar kalabalık.
Onların işte milyon nüfusu var. Mesela
şu an dünya nüfusu 8 milyarsa değil mi
1,5 milyar 2 milyar nerede? Çin'de değil
mi? E o dönemde dünya nüfusu yaklaşık
300 milyon olduğu falan tahmin ediliyor.
5060 milyonu gene nerede? Gene Çin'de.
Yani dünyadaki birlik oran genel
itibariyle Çin'de. Yani teknik olarak
baktığınızda dünyada nefes alan her 6
kişiden biri kekik gözlü. Ya adamlar
kalabalıklar ve bize sürekli de bizle
mücadele ettiler. Ama o kadar kalabalık
olmalarına rağmen bizi durduramadılar.
Ve neyi inşa ettiler?
Çin settini inşa ettiler. The great the
greatest Chinese ball. Çin settini inşa
ettiler. Çin settin'in bende bir tarımı
var. Yaz de ki Çin setti iki nokta üst
üste.
Adamın bizim atamız Türkten korkusunun
uzaydan görüntüsüne ne denilirmiş?
Çinsetli denilirmiş. Ama Çin setli
uzaydan görünüyor mu? Görünmüyor. Bir ve
bu abim alt çok şey bu ha. Çok uzun bir
yol. Buradan böyle kıvrım büktüm, kıvrım
büktüm, kıvrım büktüm, kıvrım büktüm
buraya kadar getirmişler. Peki bunlar
Çin settini Türk akınlarını durdurmak
için yaptılar. Peki soru, Çinlilerin
yaptığı o Çin setti, o devasa yapı yani
ne bileyim işte 10 katlı apartman boyu
kadar adam ne dikmiş? Şey dikmiş, set
dikmiş. Biz oradan geçemeyelim diye.
Üçünde iki tane at arabası rahatlıkla
gelip geçebiliyor. Peki bu kadar
yaptıkları bu devasa yapı biz Türklerin
akınlarını durdurabildi mi, durduramadı
mı? He durdu. Nah, durdurdu diyorsun
değil mi? Hayır abiciğim durdurdu ama
senin düşündüğün gibi değil. Nasıl oldu
o olay? O olay abeciğim şöyle oldu.
Hemen atımı getirin. Retroyancılık at
verin bana. Bizimkinler atlara
atladılar. Tamam. Ellerinde kılıçlarıyla
gökten göktengri göktir diye böyle
koştura koştura. Geldiklerinde bir
geldiler bir baktılar ana ne var? Kılıcı
da çektik. Saldıracağız ama. Abim inşaat
var. Türklerin milli sporları ne? Kurban
olduklarım benim. Bizim milli
sporlarımız ne? Bir güreş. 2 cirit. 3
ne?
Üçüncüsü ne?
İnşaat izlemek. İnşaat. Abim bizimkiner
gelir gelmez. Gerçi bu olmadı lan. Benim
bküm vardı. Nereye gitti la o BK? Erdem.
Ha tamam. Bizimkiler geldiler bir
baktılar inşaat var. Bizimkiner işi gücü
bıraktılar. Atları köşeye park ettiler
ve hemen oradaki inşaata salça olmaya
başladılar. Dünyanın neresine gidersen
git bir iş makinesi çalışıyorsa
etrafında 4 be kişi varsa bil ki biz
Türklerdendir.
Bizimkiner atı bağladılar, çayı
koydular, çekirdek çiğenleri aldılar.
Çinli ya mı koruyorsun duvarı? Oraya
kule mi kondu lan? Ardından sonra
gelecekler canımı buradan otom oraya
oramı koruyorsun falan derken
bizimkinler böyle böyle böyle böyle
böyle bıdı bıdı bıdı bıdı bıdı bıdı
konuşuyoruz derken herifler kalabalık
çinsettini ördüler geçtiler. Bizi nasıl
durdurduklarını anladınız mı? Savaşarak
değil. Kendi öz içimizden gelen
kültürümüzle biz böyleyiz abim. Anlaştık
ama uğraştılar mı? Uğraştılar. Anlaştık.
Devasa bir yapı yaptılar. Çin setti
alakalı çok şeyler anlatılır. Uzaydan
görülüyor denilir. Uzaydan artık
görünmüyor. Çünkü etrafına şey yaptılar.
Eee, sarmaşıklar, marmaşıklar, bir
şeyler falan koydular buraya. Tamam.
Artık uzaydan falan gör. Bir de
düşünsene ya. Çinlisin. Dedenle beraber
pikniğe gezmeye gittin. Dede bu ne?
Çinsettiin niye yaptınız dese? Ne
diyecek? Ne diyecek? Ee, yani
korkumuzdan korkumuzdan yaptık mı
diyecek. Ne diyorlar? Ne anlatıyorlar?
Ben mesela gördüm Ankara'da şimdi
yetkililerle sorduydum tamam mı?
Adamlara öğlen yemeğinde burada ulusta
bir yerde elçilikten şeyleri varmış.
Sordum dedim ki sor may ask a question
dedim birader merhaba bir soru sorabilir
miyim? Good lunch. Afiyet olsun dedik.
Tamam. Dedim ki, "Why did you build the
great Chinese wall?" Dedim ki, "Çin
setli niye inşa ettiniz? Bana verdiği
cevap, "To protect our country for
terrorist attacks." Ülkemi terör
saldırılarından korumak için dedi. Ben
dedim ki, "The turks, Türkler biz ne
olacağız? Vadabadas biz ne?" dedim ben
terörist attack diyor. Hiç Türkten
korkuma yaptım der mi? Kurban olduğum
yani en eski medeniyet aslında biziz.
Var. Lolan güzeli diye bir şey çıktı.
Mumyamız çıktı mesela. Bak internetten
araştırın. National Geographic Discovery
de ben oralarda ne mücadele ediyorum ben
sen bir görsen sen sanıyor musun abi 23
26 42 diye. Eee dünya yetmez kurban
olduğum her yerde biz adımızı duyurmaya
çalışıyoruz ama biz sahip çıkmayınca
bunlar üzerlerine konuyorlar. Anlaştık
bilin. Hah Çin setli meselesi bu. Bunu
İslam Türk tarihinde daha da ayrıntılı
anlatıvereceğim orada geçtim. Ve Çin'in
buluşları var abi. Bu Çinliler hakikaten
de kafaları çalışan millet tamam mı?
Niye? Zora gelince bulmuşlar. Mesela
ipek. Biz Türklere ipeği bedava veriyor.
Neden?
Şundan dolayı abi. Bak biz deri
giyiyoruz. Deri savaşçıyız biz. Tamam
mı? Böyle halesi motorcusu gibi böyle
deriler, kılıçar bilmem neler böyleyiz.
Ama ipeği giydiğin anda şimdi ata nasıl
bineceksin? ipek gömlekler, rıptı
şambırlar, fularlar,
kadehler, leşantam kan bizi böyle ne
bileyim böyle yumuşak şey böyle hale
getirmeye çalışıyor. Savaşçılık,
erkekçilik özelliklerin gitsin istiyor.
Bakal ipek mesela kadınlar için çok
kıymetli bilin. Beraberinde pusula
bunlar bulmuş. Usturlap, Musturlap diye
biz de aldık mesela Barut e filmi var ya
Çinsetli diye. Ha Çinsetli diye film
var. O filmde abeciğim Çin'e Çinsettin'e
oraya Türkler saldırmıyor. Uzaylı
yaratıklar saldırıyor. Böyle böyle
subliminal mesajlarla çocukların
kafasını zeynini beynini yıkamaya
çalışıyorlar. İşte bizimkiner de diziye
mi bakar? Dizide gördüğüne mi inanır?
Kitapta okuduğuna mı inanır? Tabii ki
dizide gördüğüne inanır. Filmde
gördüğüne inanır. Al bilin barutu mesela
buldular. Onlar için o siyah toz önemli
kağıt. Çinliler buldu. Çin'den sonra ilk
kez Semerkant'ta biz ürettik. Mürekkep,
matba, yelkenli, porselen ve entrika.
Bunlar hep kimden çıkma? Çin'den çıkma.
Çinli en çok aşırış millet kim? Biziz.
Biz bunları Çinlilerden öğrendik mi?
Öğrendik. Uygurlar zamanından bizim
atiker sıralı sistem hareket tarf
tekneğine dayalı matbaamız yok mu? Var.
Ee sonra biz İslam'ı kabul ettik.
Araplar öğrettik. Has savaşlarıyla
Avrupa'ya geçti. Çin buldu, Türk taşıdı,
Arap sattı. Avrupalı aldı. Al. Bu tarz
ürünler kültürlerin ortak ürünüymüş.
aklına yattı mı? Ve entrika denince akla
tamam şimdi buldum. Şu üçünün aklı
gelir. Şu üçünün adı gelir. Kim onlar?
İlki Çin. Çinli prensesi gönderir.
Tigini tigine düşürür. İkincisi Roma.
Bizans. Hangi Bizans? Atlama hemen. Kötü
kadın Bizans değil mi? Kahpe Bizans.
Hemen onlar Bizanslı prensesi gönderir.
Şehzadi'yi Şehzadi'ye, Meli'yi Meli'ye
düşürür. Üçüncü ve en tehlikelisi
entrika İngiltere'dir.
İngiltere diye yazılır, entrika diye
okunur. Olaya girer, çıkar, herkes
birbirini düşünür, kenara çekilir.
Rahmetli babaannem gibi ben bir şey
etmedim ki der. Anlaştık. Çin entrikası,
Bizans entrikası, İngiliz entrikası
bitmez. Bilin al Çin'den. Genel bu.
Şimdi MEB'in kitabı burayı yönetenler,
yöneticiler diye şurayı bir ayırmış.
İşte hukuk, din diye şurayı bir ayırmış.
Bilim sanat diye şurayı bir ayırmış.
Ticaret ekonomi diye bir ayırmış.
Hepsini bir yerde verdim. Anlaştık. Bir
numara kimi hallettik?
Bir numara Çin'i hallettik. Ama hala
oradalar mı? Hala oradalar. La dünyaya
gitsin gene bunlar gitmez. Kalabalıklar
çünkü. 2 numaraya geldim. Kime? Hint.
Zomzomla beni erdi. Hemen köşeye.
Dırının gel. Aha. Hint ulusu ise hah
Hindistan'da burası biraz değişik.
Buranın da şöyle bir özelliği var. Bir
Hindistan'da uluslaşma süreci geç
tamamlandı. Yani bir Hint ulusunun
oluşması, bir Hint ulusunun oluşması çok
uzun zaman aldı. Neden? Neden? Çünkü
bunun birkaç sebebi var. Mesela ilki
bunlar sürekli istilaya uğradılar. İyi
de bir yer sürekli istilaya uğruyorsa
lan ne var da uğrar istilaya? Ne var
abim? Burasın toprakları çok verimli.
Hint filmlerinde görürsünüz. Tamam mı?
Heriflerin verimli neyleri var? Verimli
toprakları var. Tarım çok iyi. Bir
ekiyorsun, 1000 alıyorsun, bir eki 3.000
alıyorsun. Daha ne istiyorsun? Allah'tan
belı mı istiyorsun? Ne? İklim işte buna
uygun. Ama bunların iklimi çok sıcak.
Aşırı fazla manyak. Sıcak. Tamam. E çok
sıcak olunca bir de bunlarda ne dinleri
var? Manzmizm dini. Bak manyezm budizm
aslında Hint dinidir. Hindistan'dan çok
nerede yayılmıştır? Çin'de yayılmıştır.
Niye? Kalabalıklar çünkü değil mi? E
manizm dininde et yemek yasak. Eee et
yemezsen ne yersin? Ot yersin değil mi?
Eee ot yiye yiye maydanoz, brokoli, ne
bileyim karnıbahar, havuç haşlı brokoli
kızartaraktan eee ot gibi olursun. Et
yemezsin. Neyi kaybediyorsun? Savaşçılık
özelliğini kaybediyorsun. Bir de manizm
dininde öldürmek yasak falan filan
diyorlar. Budizimde de çongırlı çongırlı
tongırlı ya çongırlı tongırlı tongırlı
falan deyip böyle adamlar neyi kaybetti?
savaş özelliğini kaybetti. Misal kim
istila ettiyse de Hindistan'ı elini
kolunu sallaya sallaya aldı. Mesela ben
geldim Hindistan'a çöktüm, vurdum,
aldım, ettim, öttürdüm hepsini değil mi?
Çöktüm değil mi? Ama aldıktan sonra
Hindistan'ı iki hafta sonra sıcak öfti.
Ay ay cehennemin kapısını açık mı
bıraktılar? A bu ne? Bu sıcak. Öf klima
yok. Yandım bittim gittim de yemek
yiyeceksin de o sıcakta et yenir mi?
Yenmez. E ne yiyeceğiz ya? Bir maydanoz
mu limonlasak? A bir brokoli mi yesek?
Ay ne bileyim şöyle bir işte karnıbahar
mı çiçek mi kızartsak falan diye diye
diye diye savaşçılık özelliğim gitti.
Aradan iki yıl geçti. Başka bir uygarlık
geldi beni işgale. O kadar artık
geçmişim ki kendimden. Ay aman Allah
belasını versin. Ülkesin alın sizin
olsun. Ay aman ne savaşacağım bu
sıcakta? Aman verin bakayım benim işte
avokadolu sandü deyip adam bıraktı
gitti. Elini kolunu sallaya sallaya
geldiler aldılar. Bakmak şimdi
Hintlerinde atıyorlar da atıyorlar değil
mi? Hah. Bir bu tarım iyi, iklim sıcak
Malizm Budizm etkisiyle istilaha
uğradıklarında başarısız oldular. Bir
olay daha var. Hindistan ulusunun geç
tamamlanmasında. Sürekli silah
vurmalarıyla beraber bir de kast sistemi
var. Hindistan'da
bu adamlar sınıf ayrımını yukarı banda
çıkarmışlar. Acayip yukarı banda
çıkarmışlar. Nasıl? Kast sistemi
sınıflar arası sınıflar arası geçişin
mümkün olmadığı baban neyse sende olsun
geçişin mümkün olmadığı
son derece katı sınıflı toplum yapısına
ne deniliyormuş? Kast sistemi
deniliyormuş. Halk bölünmüş. Brahmanlar,
din adamları işte Vaysiyalar,
Kişatryalar, Südralar. Bir de neler var?
Paryalar var. Köle.
Bu en ayrıcalıklı bu Brahmanlar. Din
adamı muhabbeti hep zaten onlar öyle
götürüyor. Din bir muhabbetini
götürüyorlar. Anlatıvereceğim biraz
sonra geri gelecek. Tamam. [homurdanır]
Bunlar ayrıcalıklı ve baban Brahmansa
sen de Brahmansın. Baba neyse sen de
oradan devam ediyorsun. Vayası, kışatası
işte işçiler, askerler, çiftçiler,
bilmem neler falan falan diye gidiyor.
Paryalar ise köleler. Bunların hiçbir
hakkı yok. Hint fakiri diyorsun ya işte
hiçbir hak yok. Bunlar toprağın
üzerindeki ağaç gibi. Toprakla beraber
alınıyor, satılıyor. Aynı bizim Şaban'ın
filmi gibi. Vallah sataram köyü ha diyor
ya bu benim Enes adamımdır diye. Al aynı
onlar hiçbir hakları yok. Ve bak hani
Hintleri. Bak mesela Bollywood diye bir
şey duydunuz mu? Bollywood. Bu
Hintlerinin çekildiği yerler. Allah'ım
atmasyonun atmasyonu lan. O [öksürme]
pandemi zamanı ya Rabbi yapacak iş yok.
dersler, mersler falan hep gitti. Sap
gibi kaldık. Tamam. Netflix'te izleyecek
dizi yok. Netflix'e bir dizi geldi. Şey
film geldi. Bahubali
2 bu5 saat oturduğumuz dedim. Allah'ım o
Hintlerine hasta oluyorum ben. Tamam mı?
Ne dansları bitiyor, ne kıyafetleri
bitiyor, ne bakışları bitiyor, ne olay.
Lan bizim Kara Murat Battal Gazi filmine
şey yapıyorsunuz. Surdan atlıyor da 10
kişinin üstüne ölüyor ya. Lan bunların
filmi bizle. Kurban olduğumun herif
göktelenden gökteleni atlayıp
aşağıdakileri darıyor. Sonra onlardan
önce gidiyor. Hani var ya bizim
Instagram'da bir tane eleman var ya
nişan aldım komutan yanımda tak sıktım.
Komutanım sen dur dedim gittim mermiyi
yakaladım. Komutanım dedim buyur mermi.
Oğlum o bile onların yanında
Hollywood'un yanında vallahi solda sıfır
kalıyor ya. Hala o bir de bitmiyor
bunların ingilizceleri de komik
bunların. Tamam mı? Çongırlı çongırlı
çongırlı. Ya ya
what are you doing my brother
my brother what are you doing diye
görürsünüz kendilerini belli ediyorlar
ama şu an günümüzde bu Hindistanlılar
özellikle bu yazılım sektöründe günümüze
bak al bak günümüze kadar getiriyorum
sana yazılım sektöründe bu adamlar
iyiler haberiniz olsun Hint Fakiri deyip
geçmeyin. Hollywood onların film
Amerika'nın Hollywood'una karşı
yaptıkları yer. Ama işte köle hiç bakı
yok. Hatta size bir de genel kültür
bilgisi. Hintli kadınların kafasında bir
tane kırmızı nokta oluyor. Bildiniz mi?
O ne demek? O kırmızı nokta evli mi,
bekar mı, Müslüman mı, Brahman mı, alt
sınıftan mı, üst sınıftan mı, köle mi,
soylu mu? Hangisi? O kırmızı nokta
onların evli olduğunu gösterir. Kim 500
milyar ister 250 milyarlık soruşturur.
Bak bunlar hep yeniden kültür olsun
söyle. Ve hakikaten çok katı artık abim.
Paryalar, südralar, kışatryalar, Viyalar
ayrı ayrı dil konuşuyor. Hani Hintleri
acıklı olur. Kızla oğlan birbirini sever
de kavuşamaz. Değil mi? Bizde de var.
Niye? Bizde fakir zengin. Bunlar da ölü
abi. Bunlar da sınıf farkı. Oğlan bir
sınıftan, kız bir sınıftansa mümkün
değil bir araya gelemezler. Mümkün
değil. Bak gene bunu anlatıp da Oscar
ödülü alan bir film var. Çok soruları
mesela Slamd milyoner diye kim 500
milyar isterin Hint versiyonu. Çocuk
soruları doğru biliyor. bile
yanlış cevap veriyordu. Bilemezsin.
Niye? Sınıf atlamasın diye. Al. Şimdi
böyle bir durumda halk bir bütün
olabilir mi? E olamaz. Uluslaşma süreci
niye geç tamamlandığını anladın mı?
Sürekli istilaya uğra sınıf sistemi var.
Ben yemişim. Hindistanlı muhabbetine
geliyor. Anlaştık. Peki Hindistan'daki
bu sistem ne zaman sona erdi?
Hindistan'da bu sistem Gazneli Mahmut'un
17 Hindistan seferiyle sonat putkran
dediği seferlerle sona erdi. Hindistan'a
düzenlediği 17 seferle Gazneli Mahmut
neyi yaydı? İslamiye'ti
yaydı. Hayırlı uğurlu olsun. İslamiyetin
özünde de eşitlik var mı? Eşitlik var.
Kast sistemi ne oldu? Trıt gitti.
Anlaştık. Ama ilerleyen süreçte
İngilizler gene 1600'lü, 1700'lü
yıllarda İngilizler burayı işgal
ettiler. Sömürgeleri haline getirdiler
ve orada yeni bir sistem getirdiler.
Kas sisteminin güncel versiyonu Raja lık
diye bir sistem getirdiler. Hala
etkileri devam ediyor. I. Dünya
Savaşı'ndan sonra Hindistan da ayrıldı.
Hindistan Pakistan ayrıldılar. Hala
Keşmir sorunu devam eden Hindistan
Pakistan arasında. Tamam ama hala şey
devam ediyor. Şu sınıfı top yapısının
etkileri devam ediyor. Al. Hint ulusunun
da ne olduğunu anladınız mı? Tamam. Hah.
Beraberinde bir de bunların yolu vardı.
Neydi o yol? Baharat yolu idi, değil mi?
Hah. Hindistan'dan çıkıp Mısır'a kadar,
İskenderiye'ye kadar gidiyorduz. Kapiş.
Bak bunlar hep doğu batı kültürü ile
alakalı işler. Nereden başladık? Doğudan
başladık. Gel orta kamaraya. Neyi de
hallettik? Hint de hallettik. Hadi şimdi
bir yaklaşık yarım saat falan oldu.
Uzatmayacağım bu videoları. Kısa kısa
böy noktaş noktalış falan gidelim. Siz
de rahat rahat çalışın. Sıkılmadan güle
eğlenerek dinleyin gidin. Sonra Mısır,
Roma, Ege edelim. Sonra Mezopotam
Anadolu'yu halledelim. Oradan da abdest
alın gelin. İslamiyet'ti kabul edeceğiz.
Haydi bakalım. Sonraki ders görüşmek
üzere. Eyvallah.
>> [zil sesi]